so I had some requests to do a video on
this drug called osempic and this is a
drug that's very popular which is used
for weight loss it's an injectable drug
I'm not going to deny it does work but
it comes with a package some slight
minor problems which I'll discuss but
first let's talk about why it actually
works what osempic does to the body is
it increases a certain receptor called
glp1 which helps slow down digestion
thereby decreasing your appetite
Cravings so you're no longer hungry and
you can eat less and lose more weight it
even improves the beta cells of the
pancreas to help restore insulin levels
in fact it's been known to improve
insulin resistance and anything that
improves insulin resistance will help
you lose weight it has some interesting
effects in the liver too it actually
helps a person stop making so much sugar
okay that's called gluconeogenesis and
also it helps slow the breakdown of
sugar in the liver so this is why it's
used with diabetics it can help blood
sugars it sounds pretty cool right
well it has some slight problems number
one it's a bit expensive it's between I
think 1300 to 1500 a month and it has
some slight minor side effects like
nausea vomiting bloating abdominal pain
headaches gas constipation diarrhea
heartburn and dizziness
some of those don't seem minor they seem
kind of major but let's talk about the
major side effects thyroid cancer
there's also been another side effect of
Suicidal Thoughts pancreatitis kidney
disease retinopathy which is damage to
the retina muscle loss and gastroparesis
where there's a situation where the food
is not emptying from your stomach too
well and some of these side effects
don't occur for about three days so you
have three days without any side effects
and all of a sudden they kick in and
when people get off the medications many
times they still have side effects for a
period of five weeks because it takes
five weeks to get it out of your system
and my question is do you plan on taking
this the rest of your life what are the
long-term effects of this drug
is it really going to solve your weight
loss problem without giving you another
problem but I'm going to recommend an
alternative now this relates to uh
certain herbs do you realize there are
over 200
000 secondary metabolites these are uh
chemicals in plants that have
therapeutic benefit to our bodies in
fact 50 of all drugs are derived from
these chemical compounds in Plants this
is where big Pharma gets their ideas but
of course you can't patent them so you
can't make a lot of money so they're
probably not going to be validated as
much but Chinese medicine Indian
medicine all these ancient cultures have
used plants for centuries even if we
take a look at
anti-diabetic effects there's over 400
different phytonutrients in plants that
have this interesting anti-diabetic
effect and guess what they don't give
you all these side effects in fact
rarely any side effects so if you just
do a search on the Internet or maybe
Google a scholar on glp 1 Agonist you'll
find all sorts of herbs that come up for
this two very popular ones are called
Panax Ginseng and the second one is
berberine in fact berberine is very very
potent in fact it kind of mimics the
effects of metformin so those are two
things that I would definitely include
on the list in addition to something
else which I want to recommend as well
and that is the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet
with at the same time doing intermittent
fasting because if you combine low carb
and healthy ingredients with not eating
so frequently I will guarantee within
three days your appetite is going to
disappear without an appetite without
these Cravings it will make it very very
easy to do this and include it as a part
of your lifestyle so you can do it long
term and at a fraction of the cost
you're basically going to be eating less
frequently so it's not going to cost you
any money you're just changing what you
eat and not only will your appetite
disappear and lose weight but your
cognitive function will improve you'll
have a much greater mood you'll have
improved liver function you'll have less
of a fatty liver you'll be able to
preserve your muscles your digestion
will be better I mean just that alone is
going to be huge but let's just say you
go the medical route and you do this and
you lose weight but you're tired and you
have digestive bloating and you notice
your muscles are shrinking and you have
acid reflux what are you going to do
about all those symptoms is this going
to be just taking more medication to
handle or cover up those medications I
mean you're going to feel miserable so
this is what I would recommend I would
get some Panax Ginseng and berberine
do the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet with intermittent fasting and just
get started now for information on how
to do this in a healthy way I put up
this video right here check it out